he was the flamboyant controversial
symbol of America's dogged resolve
during World War two with his trademark
corncob pipe and his love of self
publicity he is among the most well
known of war heroes though he often
disregarded Authority he was still
praised for his bold imaginative
military strategy in today's bio
graphics we look into the rather
colorful life of General Douglas
MacArthur
[Music]
Douglas MacArthur was born on January
the 26th 1880 in Little Rock Arkansas he
was the last of three sons bonza Arthur
and Mary MacArthur his father was a
Civil War veteran who had fought with
distinction in many battles he indeed
won the medal of honor for his bravery
setting a very high bar for his boys
despite his father having been the state
governor of Wisconsin Bartha fell for a
southern belle tensions were so high
between the states that Mary's brothers
refused to attend the wedding
young Douglas was heavily influenced by
his father's military career he once
commented that his first memory was the
sound of bugles and he loved the pomp
and ceremony of the army by the time
that Douglas came along Martha had been
stationed to a series of remote Western
military posts when their youngest son
was 9 years old the family relocated to
Washington DC for next four years
Douglas attended the force public school
in 1893 Arthur was posted to San Antonio
Texas there Douglas was enrolled at the
West Texas Military Academy he excelled
both academically as well as on the
sports field being named class
valedictorian during his final year his
sights were now set on West Point
Military Academy his father tried to use
his influence to secure a presidential
appointment for his son to the Academy
but this was rejected by two presidents
Cleveland's and McKinley this meant that
he would have to gain entry the
old-fashioned way by passing the
entrance exam Arthur hired a tutor to
help Douglass prepare for the exam his
diligence it paid off and he attained a
score of 93 points three out of a
hundred
MacArthur makes a comment sits on his
preparation for the exam it was a lesson
I never forget preparedness is the key
to success and victory Douglass's mother
instilled in him a firm belief that he
was destined for greatness by the time
that he entered West Point Douglas had
developed enough qualities to reinforce
that belief he was strong both mentally
and physically than from his earliest
days and military outposts in the West
he became adept at horse riding and
rifle shooting in remembering that time
he said I learned to read and shoot even
before I could read or write indeed
almost before I could walk and talk the
teenage mcarthur he was tall and
handsome and he projected an error of
self confidence that turned heads
whenever he walked into a room
[Music]
Douglass's first year at West Point was
a challenging time for him as the son of
a senior officer and with a mother who
stayed close by in a hotel to keep an
eye on her beloved boy he was subjected
to more than the usual hazing that all
the first-years have to endure still he
endured it with a stoic resolve that
impressed the senior students while
other first-year students were broken by
the less intense hazing that they
experienced Douglass was able to
maintain an air of composure even
cheerfulness throughout the ordeal
douglass proved to be an outstanding
student in all respects he graduated in
1903 first in his class with an overall
score of 98% it seemed as if his
mother's projections of greatness they
were right on track as a top graduate
from West Point Douglas was now given
the opportunity to choose which branch
of the armed services that he wanted to
enter he decided on the engineering core
entering the service with the rank of
second lieutenant his first posting it
was the Philippines which had been an
American colony for five years his
father Arthur had served there three
years earlier and he had warned his son
and whoever else would listen that an
insurrection was on the horizon on that
Island
Douglas was placed in charge of
strengthening the military
infrastructure on the island yet he had
barely been there a month when he was
attacked by a pair of bandits while
traveling alone in the countryside he
beat off both attackers and then shot
them dead it was an early example of the
Fisker egde that would go on to be as
trademark this first assignment it was
cut short after less than a year when
Douglas contracted malaria once he
recovered his father pulled some strings
to have Douglas accompany him as a
military aide on a tour of Asia the two
years that he spent in places like China
Japan and India developed within
MacArthur ideas about Asia that went
against the grain of mainstream
political thought he considered Asian
people to be equal to Americans this in
itself undercut these subtle racism
which underpinned US policy toward the
region furthermore he was of the firm
opinion that America's future lay with
the Far East and not as the majority
contended with Europe this set in rather
at odds with the European centrifuge vis
Superior's something which would persist
throughout his lifetime after his return
from Asia
Douglas spent a number of years building
up his experience in qualifications in
the end
Janee wrinkle he attended engineering
school in Washington after which he was
posted to Milwaukee and then Kansas by
that time he had been promoted to
captain in January of 1912 MacArthur was
posted to Panama this would be a short
excursion he returned the following
month to attend the funeral of his
father he was concerned about the mental
health of his mother and requested a
reposting to Washington DC in order to
be costar
[Music]
[Applause]
in 1914 macarthur was assigned to the
war department to serve on the Veracruz
expedition in Mexico relations between
the US and Mexico had been deteriorating
for some time an incident that became
known as the Tampico affair brought
matters to a head nine American sailors
were taken into custody by the Mexican
government for entering off-limit areas
of the city of Tampico the sailors they
were released but the Mexicans refused
to provide the 21 gun salute demanded by
the American government an outraged
President Woodrow Wilson ordered the
invasion of the port of Veracruz by the
US Navy MacArthur was sent to Veracruz
as a military advisor however he soon
went beyond his job description when he
recruited some local railroad engineers
and headed out to commandeer a number of
trains that were believed to be sitting
several miles down the line to get there
he and his small group used a hand car
the group were able to commandeer a
total of five engines on their way back
to headquarters they came under attack
from rebels on horseback
MacArthur shot at least three of the
attackers when he returned he noticed
that there were bullet holes in his
clothing yet he remained unscathed
MacArthur's commanding officer he was
greatly impressed by this daring
ingenuity he recommended MacArthur for
the Medal of Honor
however the honors board questioned the
advisability of this enterprise having
been undertaken without the knowledge of
the commanding general on the grounds so
by 1915 MacArthur he was back in
Washington DC where he immersed himself
in his work at the War Department in
1915 he was promoted to major the short
time later he was made the Army's first
chief of the Bureau of information which
was essentially a military press office
his experience taught him valuable
lessons about the power of the press and
the need to cultivate a very strong
public persona
[Music]
the United States entered into World War
one in April of 1917 MacArthur wanted
the National Guard to be sent to Europe
to play their part in the war effort he
came up with the idea of a rainbow
National Guard force that was made up of
Guardsmen from every state this avoided
any interstate rivalry as a results he
became chief of staff of the 42nd
rainbow division it left for France in
October of 1917 the 42nd rainbow
division was posted behind front lines
in order to complete their training
MacArthur's duties they were largely
administrative something which was a
source of great frustration for him he
longed to get in on the action going so
far as to volunteer trench raids with a
neighboring French division on one such
raid macarthur found himself unto gas
attack yet he still managed to make it
to safety the French they were extremely
impressed with his actions awarding him
the quarter ger as well as volunteering
to help on French raids he eventually
led some American ones every time he was
the first man over the top and his
bravery it didn't go unnoticed he was
awarded the Distinguished Service Cross
and in June of 1917 he was promoted to
Brigadier General he won two more
Distinguished Service Cross as leading
his men in a defensive mission during
the kaisers offensive in the summer of
1918 the horrors that he witnessed
during that offenses prompted him to
make the quip whoever said the pen is
mightier than the sword obviously never
encountered automatic weapons yes
MacArthur excels in the thick of battle
by the end of July 1918 he had earned
himself four Silver Stars two quarter
girls and the French Legion of Honor
still he wasn't done during the great
American offensive of October of 1918 he
won two more Silver Stars and despite
being gassed he refused to stay out of
the thick of the action he came into
contact with future General George
Patton who called MacArthur the bravest
man I've ever met
the climax of MacArthur's World War one
experience was the taking of the French
city of schastye on after spotting a
weakness in the German defenses he led
an attack that over round the town
the capture of Chateau was a key victory
in the final weeks of the war and it won
him yet another Distinguished Service
Medal
[Music]
returning to the United States as a
celebrated war hero MacArthur was
assigned to Camp Meade Maryland's for a
time before being returned to Washington
DC he was involved in preparing a manual
on the best use of a new weapon of war
the tank after studying the subject he
became convinced that tanks should be
used for more than just infantry support
they should constitute a separate
fighting force of their own
in 1922 MacArthur married Louise Brooks
Cromwell described by the New York Times
as one of Washington's most beautiful
and attractive young women she was also
one of the richest coming from a wealthy
dynasty Louise who brought two young
children to the marriage had previously
courted MacArthur's superior General
Pershing the older man was not happy
with the situation threatening to sends
MacArthur to the Philippines if he went
ahead with the marriage in less than a
year MacArthur was indeed sent to the
Philippines as a commander of her
brigade in the Philippine division there
was during this posting that he
established close ties to the Philippine
ruling powers he also witnessed
firsthand that poor treatment of the
indigenous people becoming a champion of
their rights in 1925 MacArthur was
promoted to Major General and brought
back to the United States as the
commander of the fourth Corps in Georgia
lingering Civil War tensions made his
command untenable and he was transferred
to the 3rd Corps in Maryland by 1927
MacArthur's marriage though there was in
trouble he and Louise they were just too
different and though he was devoted to
her two children they separated at the
end of that year and they were
officially divorced two years later in
1929 MacArthur then decided to throw
himself into a new role he was given the
role of presidents of America's Olympic
Committee for the 1928 games in
Amsterdam in one famous incident during
the games when the US boxing coach
threatened to withdraw the team due to
perceived bias on the judging panel
MacArthur pulled him aside and told him
Americans don't quit following the
Olympics MacArthur was sent back to the
Philippines then in 1930 was appointed
US army chief of staff the youngest man
at the time to hold that position he
made important administrative changes
during the difficult Depression years
yet the most noteworthy episode during
his tenure as chief of staff came in
1932 when he oversaw the Army's response
to a protest by war veterans in
Washington
during the confrontation soldiers fired
on the veterans with several of them
being killed the backlash it fell
squarely on MacArthur's shoulders and
his reputation it suffered a setback
with the election of Franklin Roosevelt
to the presidency tensions between the
commander-in-chief and his chief of
staff they reached an all-time high
when Roosevelt refused to increase the
military budget MacArthur made the
following caustic comment when we lose
the next war and an American boy lying
in the mud with an enemy bayonet through
his belly and an enemy foot on his dying
throat spits out his last curse I wanted
the name not be MacArthur but Roosevelt
despite their differences Roosevelt and
MacArthur they had a mutual respect for
one another the four-year chief of staff
post was extended by a full year by the
president in 1935 MacArthur once more
went to the Philippines this time became
at the personal invitation of President
Manuel Khe Sahn to act as a military
advisor in order to create a defense
force on the islands to take up the role
he retired from active service in the US
Army
in July 1941 Roosevelt brought MacArthur
back he appointed him commander of the
US forces in the Far East the immediate
focus naturally it was to build up US
forces in the Philippines five months
later the Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor brought the United States into
the war it seemed clear to MacArthur
that the Philippines was to be the next
Japanese target that attack came within
just two weeks MacArthur had neither the
man bow and all the time to prepare a
proper defense force and half of his Air
Force was simply wiped out on December
the 22nd Japan advanced on Manila acting
on his own initiative MacArthur pulled
his forces back to the Bataan Peninsula
he set up his headquarters on the
islands fortress of Corregidor with him
was his personal press corps which
allowed him to publicizes valiant
defenses against the Japanese however
his forces and supplies they were too
few and his situation it was hopeless
President Roosevelt gave the command
film to evacuate Bataan at first he
refused only complying when Roosevelt
promised to give him his own theater of
operations in the Pacific MacArthur he
then escaped from Bataan making a daring
getaway by sea however his forces they
stayed on the island they were overtaken
by the Japanese in April of 1942 with
many dying in the ensuing Bataan Death
March
MacArthur now set up his base of
operations in Australia it was from
there that he made his famous promise I
said to the people of the Philippines
whence I came
I shall return for two years he worked
indefatigably to make that promised a
reality Roosevelt appointed him as
supreme commander of the southwest
Pacific area he worked closely with the
commander-in-chief of the u.s. Navy
Admiral Charles Nimitz together they
devised a plan that would attack the
Japanese through the Central Pacific
Islands which was in Nimitz's focus and
then asked them from the Philippines
which MacArthur was committed to doing
they called this operation cartwheel
nimitz advanced his naval forces through
the solomon islands wa macarthur
advanced along the northeast corridor of
New Guinea
he used a strategy that he called island
hopping in which she bypassed the main
areas of Japanese strength during this
time MacArthur's reputation among the
American public it had achieved hero
status by the end of 1944 he was poised
to invade the Philippines
however the authority for the invasion
was denied by both Admiral Nimitz and
the presidents with the aid of his
well-tuned publicity machine he
due pressure a change of mind and the
go-ahead was ultimately given for the
invasion on October the 19th 1944
MacArthur landed at the Leyte Gulf over
the next few months he pushed on to
fully liberate the Philippines his men
finally crossed the central plain to
take control of the capital of Manila in
March of 1945 MacArthur received the
Japanese surrender at Tokyo Bay on
September the 2nd 1945 following war he
was placed in command of the operation
of the Allied occupation of Japan he was
charged with rebuilding the Japanese
economy and demobilizing their military
in 1950 MacArthur served as commander of
the United Nations forces in the Korean
War
his tenure it came to an unceremonious
ends the following year when ongoing
tensions with President Truman on the
approach towards the Chinese that do his
dismissal as UN commander-in-chief
Truman was attempting to pursue a
peaceful negotiation with the Chinese
while MacArthur was a vocal advocate for
military intervention the situation
became untenable when he wrote a letter
to a Republican senator calling for a
military invasion of China the letter he
was read aloud in Congress this gave
Truman the excuse he needed to get rid
of the troublemaking General MacArthur
learned about his firing through a radio
report MacArthur they was very popular
with the public and this created a
backlash against treatment with many
people calling for his impeachment with
his typical caustic style treatment
addressed the situation with the
following I fired him because he
wouldn't respect the authority of the
president that's the answer to that I
didn't fire him because he was a dumb
son-of-a-bitch although he was but
that's not against the law that generals
if it was 1/2 to 3/4 of them would be in
jail
[Music]
his firing by Truman had made MacArthur
even more popular than ever
upon his return to the US he was given a
ticker tape parade through the streets
of New York City the largest but the
city had ever seen he was invited to
give a farewell address to Congress in
which he delivered the famous line never
gone away he moved into the Waldorf
Astoria Hotel in New York where he
remained for the rest of his days his
retirement years were spent in quiet
seclusion
however in 1961 he was contacted by
President Kennedy and asked for advice
on the Asian situation
MacArthur told him to stay out of
Vietnam in 1961 MacArthur made his final
trip to the Philippines where he met
with old friends on his return to the
States he began working on his
autobiography the end came on April the
5th 1964 as a result of liver disease he
was honored with a full state funeral
with more than a hundred and fifty
thousand people paying their respects to
one of America's great Titans of war so
I really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did please do give us a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe and it
that notification bar we put out videos
several times per week so by doing that
you'll find out all about them also if
you'd like these in the audio format
maybe you drive or do things where you
can't really watch them all the time why
not check out the audio version of this
youtube channel you can find it on
itunes or wherever you get your podcasts
just search by our graphics it'll come
up and as always thank you for watching
[Applause]
[Music]